New neuropathy clinic and he died of in a soda called astute health. Do you know anything about them?
No, I don't, but here's the scoop about neuropathy. How do you treat neuropathy?
Well, there isn't any secret way to treat neuropathy. They can't do injections in your feet to treat neuropathy.
That's going to make it any better. They can't, you know, the treatment for neuropathy is going to be stimulation of
So other than doing the rebuilder
What are some other treatments of neuropathy? Well, you could do PEMF, most electromagnetic fields,
therapy on your feet. If you had a PEMF machine there, you that can be beneficial.
What are some other things you could do? Vibration, you could do vibration on your feet if you have a vibration plate.
Well, you can buy a mini vibration plate, which is like a foot, just a foot massage or a vibrator. You could probably buy that on Amazon for, you know, a couple hundred dollars.
I had them, you know, where they just kind of slant just sit in front of your chair while you're sitting watching TV and you're put, you turn it on and it has
maybe three different modes to it and it's vibrating at three different, you know, levels and it's it's meant it's not meant to treat neuropathy, but it's meant to make your feet feel better when you got sore feet.
But that can be very good. Remember, you're just firing those pathways. So
the vibration, so anything you could do to fire those pathways is going to be good for your brain. It's going to be good for neuropathy.
It's going to be good for any neurological issues whatsoever. We just treat a lot more neurology, you know, as I have tons of training and functional neurology.
And we used to treat a lot of 80, 80, 80, HD patients and such and people with cognitive disorders. And so using the rebuilder of them, even though they don't have
any neuropathy, they go, okay, why are you using something for neuropathy on my feet? I don't have foot problems. I have brain problems because it's firing to the brain.
So you're going to the most distal area and you're firing back to a ferret pathways to the brain and it's very effective at getting the brain woken up and turned on.
So, um, so what are the pathways to the a ferret pathways? Well, you have pain pathways and that is partially fired through the rebuilder.
The rebuilder is specific frequency, though, to help rebuild the nerve. So it's going to be more specific to neuropathy.
You have vibratory pathways. Those are different fibers, these vibratory receptors that are picked up in the skin.
So using vibration can be extremely beneficial. So just buying off Amazon, you know, a foot vibration pad where you put your
feet on can be very helpful. You got pain pathways that can be stimulated through just walking barefoot, you know, outside, walking in the grass to start with, walking on a gravel driveway can be a great brain therapy.
You know, how much that hurts so much? You got to walk really slow, but you're firing those a ferret pathways.
And then hot and cold, put in your feet in cold water, then put in your feet in hot water, you're stimulating the neurons.
So you're stimulating those receptors and firing those pathways. That's why PMF can be good because you're just firing into those pathways.
It's just, you know, going to a neuropathy clinic. Those are the kind of things that they're going to do. And quite honestly, you can do those things at home.
So I don't know what other benefit they would have. Certainly, I'm not knocking them. You can check into that.
You know, I don't know what else they would offer other than that, but those are the things that you want to do.
All those things I mentioned are good for neuropathy, but understand what I, what I tied to there a little bit is all those things are also good for your brain.
So any cognitive disorders, early dementia, forgetfulness, just trying to keep your brain alive is any stimulation that you can fire a ferretly back into the brain is good. So stimulation is so good.
And then obviously if you're trying to detox the area, you've got to get the lymph moving. So contraction of muscles writing your, your the alphabet with your feet. If you can't walk a lot, you're moving your feet around, try to stand up, holding on to something and doing leg razors, toe razors, you're contracted your, your lower leg muscles, the soleus and the gastroint muscles to push the lip.
On of there, you're helping your, your lower extremity detoxifying. So exercise is so important.
And then, you know, just getting out, trying to walk, trying to move, that's going to be equally important.